our next presenters both took on
troubling social problems in pictures
this year he struggled to clean up clean
gangland Chicago she worked out how to
kiss a date with a five-inch nose hello
yes the lovely Roxanne Daryl Hannah and
Kevin Cosmo
costume designers have always played an
essential role in moviemaking look at
Kevin's last three pictures he moved
from the 1870s and Silverado to the
1930s and The Untouchables to the
contemporary period no way out
distinctive convincing costume design
was absolutely essential to each on the
other hand when Darryl that her mermaid
and splash had pretty nearly put out she
merely put out the designer didn't you
that was makeup effects but at times the
job of costume designer is more
complicated than other times but it's
always an important job these talented
people share a unique bond with the
actor they help us to define our
character and they understand the vanity
that goes into it often they become one
of your most trusted friends it's with
great appreciation that we present this
award tonight and the nominees for
achievement in costume design are Jenny
Beavan and John Wright
Bob Ringwood for Empire of the Sun
Marilyn been strengthened for the
untouchable
Dorothy Jenkins for the dead
James Atchison for the Last Emperor
the winner is James Atchison for the
last
is number six my mother used to say that
a little bit of encouragement goes a
long way so I'd like to thank the
Academy sincerely for this huge piece of
encouragement I share it and I want to
thank many people 250 people in five
different countries worldwide who
supported me and created the costumes
for this movie in particular in London
I'd like to thank my assistants Frank
Gardner and Chile Hebden and Joyce
Hurley in Rome the marvelous yoga
predict Olli who did the military
uniforms Mario Kart Oni and Thomas
casterline and finally I would like to
thank Jeremy Thomas for his fearless
commitment and energy in getting this
project off the ground and finally to
Bernardo Bertolucci for his friendship
and his courage and his vision thank you